while God's have a reputation we're
being gloomy and humorless that's just
an unfair stereotype based solely on
everything about them I mean look how
much fun they're having at the annual
Disneyland gap celebration this is the
best part of Splash Mountain we last
months guys from across the country
flocked to Disneyland for the 19th
annual bats day fun in the park a time
to fill themselves with a sense of
futility of life and churros the
three-day event featured parties a black
market and constantly making tourists
ask each other is that Kim Burton over
there magician what is a ride a goth
would love at Disneyland Olivia the
emotionally haunted mansion yes Hale
what is I need my space Mountain last
word
that answer was the Daily Double
summer Cinderella's asshole yes
[Applause]